Jerry West Hall of Famer clipper special
consultant former warriors executive and
former Clippers GM former Laker GM hi
Jerry how are you I'm fine thank you are
you I'm doing okay how excited are you
well it was a pretty good Friday night I
guess a couple days ago if you get a few
days ago for the for the Clippers and
you know obviously it bought a lot of
excitement I think to everyone involved
in acquiring the two players that we
required so pretty special day for
Southern California basketball
particularly with the two guys that the
Lakers have LeBron and Anthony so been
in pretty cool time from that basketball
in Southern California what role did you
play in bringing Kawhi Leonard to town
very small okay I just had a voice our
front office is really terrific okay and
they all behind us seen sayings lawrence
franks michael winger and trent red and
they were really on top of this thing
the whole way and you know when you in
this league today it's just so different
than the players are free to move around
agents obviously employers contribute
where they go I've never seen anything
like it where players can recruit other
players but I guess it's the modern-day
NBA and that I think it's it's an
awkward situation when when you're in
these positions - I have an opportunity
to maybe acquire a player like like the
ones we've talked about and more
importantly for the team that gets them
it really does wonders for a franchise
it's just hard to describe the
excitement within the Clipper
organization I'm sure the lake
organization also but when you get Kawhi
then how long after
do you realize or is getting Kawhi you
know hinging on getting Paul George as
well like how do those two how do they
connect well obviously I think they have
great admiration for each other's game
and you know I'm I try to be a
completely fair and honest all the
players in league
but I honestly think there's a to two
best way players in basketball and to
get them on one night as I say is pretty
remarkable at our front office Lawrence
Michael and Trent Retton they all
contributed greatly to it but those
players talked and I'm not sure sure
that maybe if Hawaii had had some
influence on Paul that we would have
been able to make a deal with Oklahoma
City and obviously we paid a big price
and Oklahoma City should be I guess
exciting about their future now but it
was remarkable night and to say it you
know not again not to try to defer
anything did he other teams involved but
certainly the players helped today you
don't want any credit for this do you oh
no and I should not get very little at
all I've gotten far too much better and
I really have and and I think one of the
things I enjoy about being here and
obviously this is going to be my final
stop in my basketball life is Steve
Ballmer has really put together an
unbelievably terrific organization he
spared no expense it's it's a really fun
place to be and it's not ego driven at
all and it's just a fun place to be and
he's got a lawful lot of basketball
people over there and again I'm just
part happy to be such a small part of it
to be honest with you
are you prouder of your basketball
playing career or what you did in the
front office
they have really never looked at my life
like that at all just something I've
seemed to have a love for and I've been
able to do it for a long time have a
light in basketball and most people are
not that fortunate and particularly some
of the older players who didn't give a
chance you know started with Jerry Buss
who gave me an opportunity here in Los
Angeles to work in the front office and
things went well during that time and in
the late Mike Heisley and also late
Jerry Buss like might Heisley and
Memphis gave me an opportunity to do
something was probably the most fun time
of my life because they hadn't had much
success and and more
importantly the I think the opportunity
to work with someone like Mike Heisley
and then being a consultant with the
Warriors and their success they had up
here up there and and watch how that
organization is going now and then also
with Steve here in Los Angeles he he
just a great owner and one of the nicest
men I've ever been around in my life
I've never seen a person like this with
this success that it's just remarkable
how even killed he is if people knew how
philanthropic he was he keeps all that
stuff quiet I guess he would get mad at
me for before mentioning it's not but
he's just a remarkable man himself when
you go to dinner do you ever pick up the
check with Steve Ballmer I would pick up
the check with anyone dan and I know
you're a very rich guy so I would be
happy to pick your check I like that I
like that but but Steve Ballmer's crazy
rich no cheering well he he's again
you'd never know it I think that's one
of the charming things about him and you
know I think people always are they
always ask me what he's like and I said
he just like you and I and normal I've
never seen he's willing to spend on
players he's willing just been on
personnel within the front office and as
I mentioned before I've never been
around any organization that is better
than this one that's for sure he's where
I'm very similar to Steve Ballmer except
for he has one more team than I do and
in two more jobs than I do
Jerry so we're we're really really
really well but I have my hair well it
you know when you're around him I think
you know you don't really realize the
totality of what he has because there's
nothing ostentatious about him and all
dan and I think that's what makes it so
much fun to be around him but to say he
and his wife or to remarkable people and
to be involved with them he's very
straightforward he's no there's no no
nothing as phony about him at all and
he's a busy man he you know he'll fly
down to a game they'll fly home the next
day or that night he flew to Las Vegas
or I think the owners meeting then back
home and then back o to summer
so he's very passionate about what he
does also he's Jerry West joining us Dan
Patrick show our duo's good for the NBA
if the right ones absolutely and you
know when you're talking about you know
here in Los Angeles you know people
always put players in their place and
they there's argue for the best top
seven players in basketball when and on
respective teams so I think the games
here in Los Angeles now are going to be
fun
anxious to watch them get after each
other and it will be more like the
playoffs every game we played them I'm
sure
who would you like to have teamed up
with in your career if you had that
opportunity well I had a chance to team
up with with one incredible player when
when we were younger Elgin Baylor had a
chance to team up with another one and
we'll Chamberlain and probably the one
that had incredible passion for as of
not only as a person but as a player is
dou Russell noting he would have been
fun to play for because he brought an
element to the game that was about
winning the greatest winner we've ever
seen in our league and he was just a guy
who kind of flew under the radar but he
had like a regal like effect on the game
he just he was just incredible and more
importantly a friend and someone else
I've greatly admired for all these years
did you ever hang out with Wilt
Chamberlain socially not socially but on
the road we were together a lot after
Gaines and stuff like that I remember
one time he took me to smalls paradise
and and in Harlem was his unbelievable
experience to be honest with you but
most of the time we we had dinner
together a lot in our rooms didn't go
out very much when we were playing and
he was he was a uniquely different
person and said she has to play with a
lot of great players but I think the the
thing that many times in your life that
that'll be like indelible memory
that you have are the times you spent
with him away from the court that to me
really defines who people really are and
you know a lot of times people look at
players they just see what they
accomplished on the court but the most
important thing is what they've
accomplished away from the court and he
was he's just a good guy and different
but a good and of course Elgin was the
best of the best I I think there was a
season when you average 31 willed
average 27 and Elgin averaged 24 25 well
you know as I say I never forget there
was a cover on sports dello Sport
magazine at that point in time and they
were talking about this trio of
all-stars and you know we'll it would be
a super team it wasn't a super team it
was a team that was really good but for
some reason we were never able to
accomplish what everyone wants to
accomplish as a player and that's to win
a championship and we weren't able to do
that together
Elgin retired when when 1971-72 season
and we went on to win a championship
like that that year and without him as
Frank that's one of the saddest things
I've ever had to do to what somebody
that not only I loved as a person but he
was one of great people did you ever
want to be around just a wonderful
person no pretense to him he was who he
was
just a great player and as I mentioned a
wonderful friend do you think you
appreciated the winning as much as you
hated the losing like when you win a
championship yes you kind of expect that
but it's the losing that you don't
expect
well in our just say Dan I wasn't been
involved in 21 NBA Finals okay both as a
player and it's executive and that's a
lot and you just you get to the point
sometimes when you want to win so bad
that it it's like a it's like a
nightmare when you don't win because you
you know you give so much and people
don't realize the stress and pressure
you feel at the point in time because
you're not only playing for the team
you're really playing for the fans in
the city if you're involved in and
community pride is something that you
know I look at the Green Bay Packers for
instance a small small city and and a
very small city that's won World
Championships in more than one and you
see that is he in a big city in New
England in Boston area the Patriots
they've had a different kind of run and
so all of these teams regards to where
they are it's about community pride and
I think in a smaller community there's
probably a lot more community pride but
people do not realize just how much
players want to win and how sad it is
and I've said it many times before but
there's a lot more incredible stories in
the losers locker room and there's a
elation and winning a championship
I saw where Rob palinka said that you
know basically winning a championship or
it's not a successful season I mean well
you know Rob is Rob is very eloquent of
course and he says what he says but this
is it's difficult and the Lakers have
won a lot puts enormous pressure on
teams to have the expectation anyway
because Las Vegas does that too you know
fans betting but as I say I don't think
I would ever say that in my life it's
just not who I am but the expectations
should be very high over there can you
tell it did did you meet Kawhi Leonard I
never really haven't interviewed him I
haven't seen him interviewed that much
like like he's a mystery Gary well it's
a life in person Oh Dan I never met him
before until we were meeting we had with
him and he's a wonderful
he really is he's funny charming I think
he I say he he he he's a great great
player then he might be the best two-way
player in basketball and when you when
you're around him you don't even feel
that he's just quiet it's hard to
describe but I've always been a great
fan of his and also Paul George of
course but to have them two two on one
side that's pretty special and as I say
in Los Angeles it should be fun when
these teams play each other be like a
playoff atmosphere and the city will
probably really respond to it but he's a
great guy he just quiet and it's super
to have him on our side for a while
it's interesting the personality that he
kind of fits the Clippers personality I
don't you know where is if you go to the
Lakers I think you have to have a
certain personality or we expect a
certain personalities that seem fair or
is that sound right not really I think
anyone can fit in anywhere in this
legged you know just be yourself don't
don't try to be something or not you
know we have players in this league have
big personalities
we have other teams where you know these
players have be incredible a little bit
extra Goldust sprinkled on a mini shot
shows but also I like he's quiet
assassins myself yeah I'm I said at the
beginning I don't know if you called and
I was the front office executive I don't
know if I take your call Jerry I don't
do that anymore okay I have had some
really great people I work president
mentioned Lawrence Frank Frank's is just
incredible I've never seen anyone work
as hard as him in my life Trent resin
who he turned down an opportunity down
in and Memphis not Memphis I'm sorry
New Orleans to be the general manager
stay with us a great guy and our the
brains in our organization like I said
he's always kidding about how smart he
is
michael winger he's just done a great
job for us also so it's been to be part
of that and as I say I do have a voice
but I'm not the one who's calling people
but as I say everyone's excited about
what we've done we have to go out and
prove it on the court
we have a tremendous bench also a
tremendous if you look at the lineup we
have we can put out there you talk about
defensive players my goodness we got a
bunch of them and and it should be a fun
year for all I just can't imagine what
did you ever feel sorry for Charlotte
where you called up and said you know
what we're gonna trade latte and he
would like Kobe I mean come on you had
to know well you know I think we all
have favorite players and draft and to
me he was a pretty easy selection I
thought he was the best player in the
draft to be honest would have said that
before and you know our again our hopes
were to try to be able to acquire a free
agent and certainly that was Shaquille
O'Neal we were able to do that and one
of the things I said to Shaquille when
we're talking at that point in time we
could only talk to fitting me with them
and we talked a lot and I never met him
before we got to be good friends over
the phone and it was amazing to talk
about I know anything I said to him I
don't believe that you ever say anything
derogatory about a franchise I think you
have to extol the virtues of the
ownership and also the people you're
working with you should never talk
derogatory about another franchise and
when players leave they have the right
to lead today but at that point in time
it was much more easy I think to make
deals because you didn't have agents
involved you didn't have players telling
you where they wanted to go at that
point in time people were pretty loyal
and it's completely changed the
landscape has changed and you know who
wouldn't want to play for some of the
team's knees legs with these historic
names over the years and certainly the
Lakers won at that point in time and to
get your kill and to get a young puppy
and Kobe Bryant it was pretty special in
here
well congrats Jerry whether
you had a large role or small role view
you've got two great players there and
should be a fun time in Los Angeles we
always appreciate talking to you
good day and great to talk to you in my
best that's Jerry West Hall of Famer the
Clippers special consultant for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR Live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]